the girag an experience don't tell you
what about a wrestling pero me
Pentimento tower and I said MMA his he
even though he wrestled he wanted to MMA
he was telling me last night that he
would watch those videos people would
smuggle UFC fights into Cuba and it
wasn't nothin it wasn't gonna happen for
him in Cuba it was never gonna happen
right so he wanted to get into MMA so
when he went to Germany he stayed and
there was an MMA fight and they wouldn't
let him fight amateur because he was in
the Olympics right so they threw him
right into the Wolves hmm like his first
fight we didn't even train he's very
funny because so you can see my de
France fight when I have it this man you
see what I do like is I when I fire the
guy that's it what happened just online
can we find the video yeah you can't you
can't he can find the video and it's in
Germany in Germany yeah how long did you
live in Germany for this year six years
Wow yeah
this started from the bottom didn't know
what he was doing here it is
is this it no no this that's a certain
like a tournament doesn't know anything
that seems like jujitsu yeah this is an
one tournament but yeah yeah that's a
one tournament is that MMA or jooge it's
not MMA that's it my man
thanks to me like you're on a big
basketball court yeah that's what I
think all MMA should be on all right
find that um so when you had the first
fight you had no training just just your
wrestling reasoning but you know how to
box a little from yeah you know right
every time you keep on because in kit
misnomers you have a glove as the
people's okay boxing right right I did a
big industry you know right just [ __ ]
around yeah yeah Wow so when you were in
Cuba were you thinking about the future
that there was only so many more years
you can compete in wrestling and
what else to do core to top and sand on
here for doodle you had this huge
wrestling career main goal Uhtred
meddled in all these international
competition mundo see you talking son
doing MMA see ya I think an MMA no MMA
UFC yeah here it is is this it right
here
yeah wow this is crazy look he throwing
kicks man and this is no training no no
wild you take oh man those are wild
uppercuts but still throwing shots to
the body
oh they give us standing 8-count what
are they doing here so what that is
this guy's got headgear on interesting
and what year was this Daniel because
the coaches you know nothing about
boxing not really their coaches keep
going yeah look goes again
yeah okay so he's trying here bones
see key see you you in this thing in
Spanish yeah
Cuban language she can hear the people
use to the lottery because there's
Cubans there a Cuban population in
Germany whoa okay so is there a big
queue not like once a month
yeah there's a big you know where else
there's a lot of Cubans that Joe where
Italy yeah they all went to I met this
Cuban girl he goes I'm never coming back
to the states if he's a lot better
vision oh yeah good food
I was a chef in Italy and he shows he
works in a restaurant but he was a
waiter they kind of understood the
language was a lot better than living
their home really really he went back he
couldn't get a job
[Applause]